[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE ELLIOTT: Hello and welcome.
I'm Dave Elliott, Global Product
Lead for Storage Products
here at Google.
I'm a former backup admin
and spent most of my career
in storage and backup.
Over the last four years,
I've been helping Google shape
its Cloud Storage offering.
And today, we're here to talk
about the economics of tape
versus cloud and what the real
costs are associated with each.
So a few things
before we get started.
First, this is a
construct or a discussion.
Right?
It hopefully will
provide a way for you
to think about the
cost of tape and cloud
and it will open up a dialogue
for you and your team.
It's not formal, it's
not highly produced,
and it's probably wrong
in a lot of areas.
Second thing, tape isn't
going away anytime soon.
Right?
So there's lots of
significant sunk cost in tape
and there's real
benefits of tape.
Really the question we're
trying to answer today
or the dialogue we're having
today is what's changing?
Right?
There's a changing landscape.
There's changing technology,
there's changing requirements,
and there's changing
possibilities.
A third is, frankly, I'm biased.
Right?
I worked with tape
early in my career.
I work with cloud now.
Another bias is
I live in the US,
but I work with customers
all over the globe.
I guess another caveat
is that I recognize
that there's many different
variables associated,
many assumptions.
No two architectures
are the same.
No two networks are the same.
No two policies are the same.
I recognize that up front.
Again, this is intended to
be just sort of a dialogue
and discussion,
maybe a construct
for you have a dialogue
with your team.
And some things I assume are
a wash between tape and cloud
so we're not talking a lot
about things like security
in this conversation.
So with that, let's
go ahead and get
started on the economics
of tape versus the cloud.
As an agenda today, I wanted to
go through these five things.
Let's start off with
tape and cloud uses.
So there's good reasons
that both of these
exist and now that
there are beginning
to be some overlap between cloud
storage and long term archival
or long term storage, I want
to start the conversation off
with a look at how the two
of them compare historically.
Second, and then really the
heart of the conversation
here, is the capital
and operational cost.
And I, again, wanted to
create sort of a construct
as things you
should look at when
looking at both the
upfront investment capital
cost and then the ongoing
cost for the operations.
Number three,
examples and tools.
So hopefully I'll open up
an online calculator here
where we can look at a real
example of tape versus cloud
and talk a little bit
about future considerations
and next steps.
So with that, let's go
ahead and get started.
If you have to drop
early from this webinar,
these are the key
decision drivers
or the things that
maybe stand out
a little bit when you looking
at the economic considerations.
As we walk through the
spreadsheet in a bit,
these are things you really
think about as differentiatives
because, again, no two
environments are the same.
First, durability.
So if you have a high
requirement for durability
that significantly impacts the
economics of tape versus cloud.
Second, personnel
cost and efficiency.
If you have high
personnel cost and
or low efficiency or the
other way around, again,
that's going to
significantly impact
the differences in the economics
between tape and cloud.
Third, data optimization.
I'll talk a little
bit about this
because this is one that is
usually missed when talking
about tape versus cloud.
It's what you can do to
remove redundant data,
to remove garbage data, and
to optimize the amount of data
that, in fact,
needs to be stored
for a long period of time.
And then close with or think a
little bit about data utility.
Right?
So what's the
greatest use you're
getting out of that data
that's stored long term?
It's stored in tape or
it's stored in cloud.
So those four things
I'll walkthrough,
I'll get to these as we talk
over the next few minutes
and wrap with it at the end.
Durability, personnel cost,
data optimization, data utility.
So let's take a quick step
back and reiterate or revisit
why tape and cloud exist.
[INAUDIBLE] probably most of you
use tape because it's portable,
it's durable, it's
inexpensive, it's cheap,
and it is installed already.
Right?
There is a sunk cost.
You've got this
investment, actually,
not just in the
hardware, but also
in the time it takes to
understand how to operate it.
So tape exists for good
reasons to get your data,
to get your data off
site, and it's portable,
and it really works well.
Cloud, on the other
hand, really came up
through a sort of the concept
of outsourcing or moving
your power, your
cooling, your redundancy,
moving the requirements
of availability
and a whole bunch of other
things off to somebody else.
Letting you focus
on what you do best.
Right?
You don't need to worry about
the mechanics [INAUDIBLE]
infrastructure,
instead you can worry
about focusing on
things that allow
you to do things differently,
differentiate yourselves.
Now I think it's
really important
when we talk about tape
and long term storage
that we call out this classic
difference between backup
and archive.
A lot of people
conflate the two.
Backup really is about recovery.
It is a really
important distinction.
It's a second or third copy,
while archived is really
for legal or
regulatory requirements
usually to meet
an important SLA.
It's also the case that
some people turn backups
into archives which is a
cause of significant, really
significant inefficiencies.
So that is sort of a
background or a precursor.
Let's get into the heart
of this conversation--
the capital and
operational cost associated
with both tape and cloud.
So at a high level
disk, tape, and cloud--
so I've included
disk here-- if you're
looking at the cost
of long term storage,
this is a very just get
high level snapshot.
Capital outlay, the
winners are here in green.
Capital outlay cloud wins
because there's virtually
no upfront capital outlay.
Capacity costs, usually
tape wins when you just
look at the cost per
terabyte or per gigabyte
over a period of time.
From a capacity standpoint,
it's usually tape that wins.
Shipping and logistics, cloud
wins because there are none.
You don't ship it.
You don't ship disk.
You don't ship tape.
I mean you don't ship cloud
like you ship a disk or a tape.
Networking cost, tape wins.
There's none or
very low, in fact.
Personnel cost is lowest
with cloud or disk
because they're more automated,
more direct processes.
And recovery costs are low
with cloud and disk, as well.
But what I really want to focus
on here are tape and cloud.
There's been a lot
of conversation
on disk versus tape
and now I really
want to talk about
cloud and tape.
So let's first go deep on the
capital upfront cost of tape.
Now if you use tape
today, hopefully this
will look familiar to you.
The biggest upfront cost
is buying your library,
buying your autoloader.
This can range from 3k to 50k or
into the hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
It could be a little
bit lower-- I've
purchased an autoloader
that cost less than that--
but it also could
be a lot higher.
I've seen libraries that run
into the hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
It's typically capitalized
over three years,
but the lifespan typically
is longer than that.
The next thing that people think
about in terms upfront cost
is tapes.
You need to buy tapes up
front both for your backup
and archival.
And this can significantly
vary depending
on what your backup
schedules are,
but generally, you might pay
somewhere between $30 and $150.
I think the street
price for an LTO-6
is around $30 and the LTO-7s
up around $130, $140 right now.
And they're rated for
long periods of time,
but nobody or very few people
or very few sophisticated people
that I know actually trust
those long periods of time.
You may need to
make improvements
to your server and your
networking or your SAN.
You may have to make changes
to your server and maybe buy
a fibre channel card,
things like that,
in order to backup or move
your data to a tape device.
And then, of course,
these are physical devices
that need to be shipped.
They need to be unpacked and
plugged in and put in a rack.
Then they need to be
physically managed
up front so these are the costs.
You have to buy the loader,
you have to buy the tapes,
you have to make changes to
your server, your networking,
and then you have to actually
spend some money up front
to get the thing started up.
Generally high cost.
Now let's move
from upfront cost.
I should say for cloud, I've
originally had made a slide
and said, these are the
capital costs upfront.
Really, are no capital
costs up front for cloud.
The capital cost
up front for cloud
are really just a
learning curve it takes
and it's very, very small
learning curve, low learning
curve.
So let's move from
capital cost up front cost
to operational cost.
Right?
Or these are your ongoing
expenses, in fact.
Let's start with cloud.
And these are the six
things that typically you
should take into
account when you
think about your ongoing
cost of storing things
long term in a cloud.
First, ingestion or getting
the data to the cloud.
This is not trivial.
If you have significant
amounts of data,
you can do it either
online directly
if you have good networks or
you can even do it offline.
You can ship drives and have
them ingested by third parties.
Storage.
Storage is typically what
people focus on the most,
and rightfully so.
It's by far, the largest
portion of your cost,
but remember storage
is all inclusive.
It gives you the high level
of 11 nines of durability.
I'll talk a little bit about
in a moment with online access
and on demand, and
all that good stuff,
but that is typically
the highest cost.
And it will range anywhere
from, at least with Google
and with other cloud
providers, this
is the general range from
2.6 cents down to a penny
a gigabyte.
Operations.
So this is our charges for
operations in the cloud.
This typically not an issue
for long term storage,
but I did actually
have a customer want
to have 800 million
files who wanted
to be kept as separate
objects and it cost him-- we
charge a penny a gig, sorry, a
penny per 10,000 operations--
so it cost him $800 to do the
puts on his operations cost.
Excess reads.
This is something that you
do need to think about.
For long term storage, our tier
that I'll talk about a minute
is Nearline and that's
intended for long term storage.
So it has a lower cost.
It's less than 50%,
closer to about 30%,
the cost of traditional
online object storage,
but it also has a cost to
read the data because it's not
intended to be read frequently.
And it's a cost of a
penny a gig for the reads.
Networking.
There is an excess
burden on networking,
but this is really tricky
because network configurations
and costs associated with them
can vary so significantly.
I think it's just
important to point out
that moving data from on-prem
to a private data center
or private data center to the
cloud for long term storage
does have some costs through
an increased network traffic.
And then finally, we are
talking about operational cost
of cloud, it's personnel.
And you're going to
find, as I mentioned
early on, one of the
overriding themes
is that cloud and
disk, for that matter,
give you the ability
to optimize your data,
to optimize your
entire corpus so you
can delete redundant
data, eliminate garbage.
And this benefit, in fact, will
require some additional effort.
So if you think about the
operational cost in cloud,
which is what we're
talking about on the slide,
you should, to be fair,
take that into account.
And there will be some effort,
but of course that effort
will payoff many times
over as you reduce
the amount of data you have.
Now let's move on to the
operational cost of tape.
And I've got two slides on this.
The first is focused on
people and infrastructure.
And again, going back to
one of my main themes,
tape is a manual process.
Right?
Tape requires you to manage,
to physically move stuff,
to grab stuff, to move it around
and that takes people to do it.
And when you're looking
at the real cost of tape,
you need to take
that into account
and you need to understand
how efficient your labor is.
You might be anywhere
from a half a person
or a quarter of a person,
up to three, four, five.
I've never seen actually
one bigger than five or six.
But there's also a significant
cost to restore data.
So now the question I
have in italics here is,
how efficient is your team?
And you need to factor
that in because it
varies so significantly.
And this is a very
significant piece
of the drivers of your ongoing
operational cost of tape.
There's also ongoing
costs associated
with your hardware,
your tape infrastructure
so the hardware maintenance
is anywhere from 19% to 25%.
You also need to
be concerned with
or think about tape
refresh maintenance.
Now you need to think about the
durability of these tapes, when
you're going to replace them.
Certain tapes are going to fail.
Also, you need to think
about the compatibility
as formats change as you move
from LTO-4 to 5 to 6 to 7 to 8.
There are some real costs
associated with that.
Off-site storage
and transportation.
Whether you pay for a service
like Iron Mountain to store
your tapes in their
own protective vault
or if you have stored in your
own secure environmentally
safe vault yourself,
these costs are, in fact,
real and never ending.
And then finally, and this is
one of the really big themes
I mentioned at the
top of this, is
you need to think about
building a redundant or durable
infrastructure.
This is a really
big one that's often
overlooked when looking at the
economics of tape versus cloud.
If high durability
is important to you,
you'll need to engineer that.
You need to engineer a
certain level of redundancy
to get that durability.
It might require two copies or
even three copies of your data.
So for cloud, 11 nines of
durability comes built in.
So for tape, this could double
or triple the calculation
to have a similar type
level of redundancy.
A real world example,
I called out here.
I had a customer who had north
of 10 petabytes of storage
that were being
put off onto tape.
They had three job
redundant copies.
They refreshed entire
corpus every five years
and they really provided
a white glove service
that did lots of testing.
This is very important
data to them.
And they calculated,
they paid about $0.04
per gigabyte per
month to maintain
that level of durability.
So it's a really
important calculation
as you think through.
It's the level of redundancy or
really a level of durability,
target durability you have.
How many nines?
The question I put here
is, what would it cost you
to delivery 11 nine durability?
How many copies would
you have to have?
Operational cost of tape.
This is the second one
I mentioned before.
Optimisations.
This is a really often
ignored, often hidden.
They're misunderstood costs.
First in any calculation,
you should take into account
the actual tape utilization.
It's not typically 100%.
Second, you realize that
there's a tremendous amount
of copied or redundant
data that needs to be
or that can be removed.
To call this redundant
data requires work.
And with data locked away on a
tape, requires a lot of work.
So much so that most people
don't put much of an effort
into cleaning up copies.
A third and related
optimization that's really hard
is just removing
the garbage data.
If you look at some
of the stats that
are on the slide, the
redundant data, the IDC claims,
there's 23 generally in
Enterprise or Global 2000
companies.
There's on average 23
copies of the same file
and look at all the different
places that a file might live,
all the different backup
copies, all the archive copies,
all the different file servers.
And it's a challenge
to remove those.
Same with garbage data.
Check Target came out
with the statistic
that a given 30% of an
average organization's data
could be deleted.
And so really the question
there is how much effort does
it require to remove this data?
What's required effort
to optimize that data?
All right.
So with that, let's move on
to really a short discussion
of networking.
I think networking
is a key thing.
It's frankly just a common
question that I get asked.
Networking, generally
the question
is something along
the lines of, hey,
my network is unreliable,
slow, and therefore,
is the cloud right for me?
A few things I'm going
to point out here.
First, backup and archives
typically an offline process.
So if we get interrupted,
they can continue
or that's a second piece.
Is they get interrupted,
they can be resumed.
And that's typically built
in to all kinds of software,
including to Google.
Network throttling's
a common feature
to make sure you don't
consume your network.
Local caching or to a
series of disk arrays,
JBOD is effective and cheap.
And DR in the cloud mitigates
many of these concerns.
So if you are going to
recover to the cloud,
then that's a
really important way
to avoid having to move
of data back on track.
And the last thing
I'll say on this
is your network can
really be a problem,
but networking speeds,
access reliability,
they're improving all the time.
And so it might not be
the right time for you
now to move to the cloud,
but keep an eye on it
because this is something
that's important to Google
and it's important to a lot
of government institutions
and lot of government entities.
Speeds are improving.
OK.
So with that, I wanted to
move to a real calculation
or example calculation.
So let me go ahead and move
over to an online calculator
that we created.
And this is really just a back
of the envelope calculator.
The things in yellow
are the things
that can, in fact,
are cells that
can be changed based
upon the assumptions
that we just talked about.
And it will
calculate out for you
here the annual cost of cloud
and the annual cost of tape.
And what I did was I
determined the annual cost
based upon multiple years.
So I made the assumption
over here the number of years
on tape, you've got the
amount of data up here,
you've got to minimum
number of copies.
Again, going back to the
what's the level of durability
you expect and how many copies
likely are going to need?
All in copies.
Then over here,
the key assumptions
are the cost of
your tape library.
I took the cost of a
Dell ML6010 library.
The capitalization period
of it I uses as three years.
The cost of IT staff
you'll find as you look
at this, a significant driver.
So I started with a
$90,000 number and then
what's the percentage of time
spent on managing that tape
infrastructure?
And number of
restores per month.
And then this last one
is really interesting.
It's what likely
optimization can you
get of that 500
terabytes or of that data
that you have up
here in cell B3?
What percentage of
that do you think
you can optimize if you
had easy access to it?
Right?
So this is the, if I can
go back and find those 23
copies that IDC says an
average enterprise has
or if I can go and find the
30% of data that's just junk
and it can be deleted.
What kind of
optimization can you get?
Because doing it in
tapes not impossible.
It really isn't, but
it's really hard.
It's just almost-- when you
talk to folks who do this,
it's just almost not worth
putting a lot of effort
into finding all that duplicate
data and all that garbage data.
So as I go through the
assumptions over here
on the right hand
side, in cost of cloud,
we've got the capacity, the
operations, the networking,
and the reads and as
you work through this--
this will be online
in a prettier format
after the webinar--
but today if you
change let's say your
cost of IT staff,
full loaded IT staff is
70,000-- see how it changes.
Right now, it's $67,000 a year
to protect that 500 terabytes.
If you go up you
say, you know what?
I can withstand lower-- I have
a lower durability threshold.
Maybe I only need one copy/
that brings down your cost.
Let's say the cost of my
tape libraries only 25,000.
You can see how that
changes the cost.
Let's say somebody actually
uses 70% or even let's say 100%.
One full person
dedicated to doing this.
You could see how your average
changes or your cost per year
change.
And of course, you
can go back here
and change the amount of data.
Say it's a full petabyte
and we need two copies.
So you can see the
difference here.
It's important to figure
out-- and the optimization's,
again, it's at 30%.
I think this is one of the
really key assumptions.
If you can get 70%, it's going
to dramatically essentially
lower the cost of
cloud because you've
removed a big part of
your petabyte of corpus
that you needed
to store on tape.
And if you think
that you're going
to get a very small
percentage, you
can see how much that increases
the cost to keeping it
in cloud.
And you can see down here
the cost assumptions I used.
The price for
LTO-6 versus LTO-6.
And this is, again,
a tool that's
going to be made available
online after this webinar.
So let's go ahead and go back
and wrap up this conversation
with some future
considerations and next steps.
We've talked a lot
about how we [INAUDIBLE]
talked about
[INAUDIBLE] and cloud
and what they were intended for.
We went in and
tried to, I think,
look at some real world examples
of costs associated with each.
But I did want to
talk a little bit
about the future of a sort
of changing expectations
and changing technologies.
So cloud offers declining
cost on an ongoing basis.
You'll see over
a period of time,
and I probably
should've included
this in this conversation, but
there's declining cost in cloud
as soon as the cost to us
or to the industry hits.
Typically, they get passed on
some relatively quick period
of time to the
end users, to you,
to the consumer of
the cloud, which
is to say very different
in a capital outlay.
Not very many
hardware manufacturers
go back to you six months
after their cost had come down
and say, hey, here's
your money back
because you've, at
that point, obviously
you've purchased that hardware.
So you have declining cost and
you have increasing utility.
And what we haven't talked about
was the increase in utility.
And what do I mean by that?
It's basically just do more
with your data more easily.
Right?
So you have lots of
data, it gets put off
on these tape drives, and the
potential value of this data
is locked away.
It's really hard to get to.
So if you had that in the
cloud, if we had that online,
you could do things
like analytics.
We have got a product that does
that called BigQuery, BigQ.
Image analysis, text
and language analysis,
we've got a vision API
and our natural languages
API that are
services that you can
leverage-- you can lay against
the data that's stored online.
But even more broadly
than that, you
can have co-mingled services
from other cloud providers.
We live in this API
world where, if you
had access to your
long term store data,
you can then do things, you
can create new businesses,
you can create new
revenue streams,
you can leverage that long tail
data that in ways you perhaps
couldn't in the past.
So again, it's really
hard because we're
talking about the economic
considerations of cloud
versus tape.
But even if you just think
about the possibilities of what
you can do with your data if
you had it globally available,
global accessible,
at a very low cost,
that's when it really
starts to get exciting.
That's when it really
changes the economics
of cloud versus tape.
So I did want to finish just
with a quick introduction
to our services, to our product.
It's called Google
Cloud Storage.
This is our object storage,
this is our blob store,
and allows you to store, access,
and manage unstructured data
on our infrastructure.
And the key things
are it gives you
unlimited scale, global
availability, high durability,
11 nines durability, as we
talked about, and low cost.
And we have three
tiers of storage.
Our Standard, our Durable
Reduced Availability,
and Nearline storage.
Nearline's the one that I've
been talking about primarily
throughout this.
That's a penny a gig per
month with a penny-- the cost
to read at a penny a gigabyte.
It's high speed.
It's, again, highly, highly
durable to 11 nine durability,
and it's low cost.
I did want to-- I get asked
this all the time-- well, how's
your cloud different?
And I wanted to call out
just a handful of things.
And you could sit through
an entire presentation
on our differentiators,
but did want
to talk about a
massive scalability,
you'll never run out of
capacity when using us.
Our global network,
we've laid fiber,
we've laid cables
across the oceans.
It's strategic to us to be
able to get data and keep data
on our network as
long as possible
because we're highly
efficient with it.
That translates into more
predictable performance
of the network when you're
using our infrastructure.
We've got low pricing.
We're proud of the fact that
we lead the industry in pricing
and will continue to do that.
We've got these
interesting cloud
services I mentioned before.
Things like machine learning
and data analytics and search
that you can leverage
against your data.
We have a single API and this
is a real distinction between us
and other cloud services.
You don't need to
have-- you don't
need to write your
data for primary
or for your standard
storage in one way
and write it in a separate
way for your archive storage.
Right?
Across all of our
tiers of storage,
it's the same single API.
And then we've got
tight integration.
I say tight integration that's
really with backup and archive
vendors.
We are not an archiving
vendor ourselves.
Right?
We work with partners.
We work with companies
like Veritas,
with Convault who have on-prem
backup and archiving software.
So at the top of
this conversation,
I talked about the
critical decision points.
Right?
Let's circle back to
these and I really
wanted to drive
home these points
as you looked at the
online calculator
and think about the cost of
cloud and the cost of tape.
First, is durability.
If you are required to
have high level durability,
then you're going
to likely end up
having to engineer that
yourself across potentially
multiple copies.
The personnel costs are high.
Rather, your personnel
cost, if they're high
and your efficiency
is low, then it's
going to impact the decision
between cloud and tape.
And again it's because tape
is such a manual process.
Data optimization.
The more data
optimization you think
you can do when you have access
and availability to your cloud,
then the more the benefits
of cloud will become reality.
And then this data
utility or this piece
of boy, if I had
access to my data,
what new and interesting
businesses could I build?
What new services could I build?
How can I get more
value from my data?
Again, in cloud, you have
access to it, you can do it,
only tape [INAUDIBLE] we can.
Durability, personnel, how much
data optimization you can do,
and your data utility.
So with that, I wanted to just
close with some next steps.
And I really think you
should keep moving.
It's great that you're
attending this webinar.
Contact us for the
online calculator.
We'll make it available.
Again, it's not perfect.
Love your feedback,
but I do want
to be able to make
sure that or I
do want to make that
available as a tool for you
in making the decisions.
Read recently published ESG
whitepaper on Data Protection
to the Cloud.
Watch our other
videos in this series.
I think all three
of these things are
at cloud.google.com/RentStorage.
We have a promotional credit
running right now, $300.
And with that $300, I
strongly recommend--
I always say this to
folks-- experiment,
experiment, experiment.
Right?
Try, try, try.
This is the beauty of cloud.
Right?
There is no huge upfront
cost other than your time
and your time can help
you determine whether this
makes sense or not.
So thank you, again.
This was a great opportunity.
Hopefully, you've found
some value in this.
I do want to go ahead and
stop sharing right here.
I do want to thank
you for your time.
This is, I think,
hopefully will give you
some things to consider.
You will have that
tool available.
You've got the
whitepaper available.
I recommend go ahead and
playing with Cloud Storage.
It's an easy thing to learn.
It's a low cost.
Again, we have a $300
credit running right now.
Thanks so much for your
time and look forward
to working with you to help
you learn a little bit more
about cloud and how
it compares to tape.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]